see what's happening the cost at
fuel pumps the price of food cost of
energy we all know how tough
it is
and how tough it can be
and
as with covid
we see the same waves the same problems
around the world in america in
europe in australia
and we can see the causes
as clear as day
first the disruption in supply chains
and the sudden demand for oil and gas as
the global economy came out of covid and
then a new surge in prices caused by
putin's aggression
the surge in the price of oil and gas
now as the world struggles to end its
addiction to russian hydrocarbons the
surge in the price of food 25 million
tons
of grain
grain the world desperately needs
still locked up in silos in odessa
because the black sea is now littered
with mines
and of course we're going to get through
this and the the markets will eventually
adjust and new supply will come on
and prices will come down again and
in the months ahead we are going to have
to do what we did before
we're going to use our fiscal firepower
that we built up uh that we have
to help we're going to put our arms
around the british people again as we
did during covet and never forget
there's only one reason
why we were able to
produce to afford furlough and all the
400 billion pounds worth of support
and that was because we conservatives
had managed the economy sensibly and
responsibly
and there's only one reason now why our
economy is strong enough
to continue to help
and that is because we took the tough
decisions and got the big calls right
when by the way labor was telling us to
stay in lockdown
and mark drakeford i think actually
criminalized people for going into the
office didn't he
neighbors
tells you all you need to know
remember captain hindsight telling us it
was reckless to open up the economy in
july last year well uh we ignored him
and weren't we right
just as we ignored him over ignored
labor over a christmas and a new year
and that's why because we took those
tough decisions youth unemployment is at
or near a record low we have half a
million more people in payroll
employment than before the pandemic and
our economy is now bigger than before
covid and at the same time
as we use our economic strength that
we've built up
to help people through the postcovid
aftershocks
we're going to do the necessary thing
we're going to fix the underlying
problems
just as we did with kobe remember
while labor
vacillated we vaccinated and let me ask
you
where was that oh who was asked who was
vaccinated with astrazeneca by the way
fantastic
good for you so was i uh
let me ask you where that precious fluid
was bottled
close
who said macclesfield graham
mackelsfield is only partly right
millions and millions of doses were
produced in wales
in wrexham in wrexham by the way that is
now represented by a conservative mp for
the first time not in a generation but
for the first time since 1935
wrexham
wrexham that now has a state-of-the-art
vaccine manufacturing plant
the motto of the family is walk heart
they believe in heart in heart walk uh
if that would have been unimaginable 25
years ago when i uh first campaigned in
the in the adjacent in the adjacent
scene by the way that seat two uh now
has a conservative member of parliament
and
the same wrexham the same wrexham uh
that today i think we can announce or
maybe it was yesterday i can't remember
her majesty has now accorded the status
of a city uh for her jubilee year and
wales wales will be at the heart of our
mission now to fix the underlying issues
in our energy market all the things that
previous governments have failed to
address whales with its boundless
potential for clean energy of every kind
we're massively accelerating our program
of offshore wind and particularly off
the coast of south wales we're putting
in now we've announced today another 160
million pounds worth of investment into
port facilities that will enable the
companies to come and
install and build uh the turbines that
we need so that we can take our offshore
wind capacity i mean we're already the
saudi arabia of wind but we're going to
take it uh from 11 gigawatts now to 50
gigawatts of wind uh by 2030. that's
that's 50 gigawatts from offshore wind
that's half the total electricity
consumption
of the uk
and wales with its nuclear heritage and
potential squandered under labour which
we're now reviving
with a new reactor every year rather
than every decade
not justin wilfred i can think i can see
a atomic kitten
there in the front row
but today i can tell you that we're
looking to build another small modular
reactor on the site at transfinith
did simon say that already
[Applause]
i couldn't i i i hope you i i hope this
is news to you but but it's i think it's
fantastic news
and that is how it's by investing in
nuclear by the way 50 gigawatts what
gigawatts bottle win 25 gigawatts of
nuclear that's how we will make sure
that we have the
base load not just for uh british
households uh for people who are feeling
the pinch make sure we don't have this
problem again but for our industry for
our businesses from welsh steel to the
welf welsh aircraft uh manufacturing
that makes half the wings of all the
passenger jets in the world i think i
think i think simon may well have said
that but it's worth saying
again to the electric heaters warming
the
lambing sheds of wells they probably
they probably stopped warming the
landing showers and wells now but they
still uh agriculture needs uh energy
welsh business uh needs energy and we
will provide uh and the whole problem
not just wales but the whole country uh
with long-term long-term uh low-carbon
secure
and dependable supply
and
the the reason we're going ahead at this
scale and this pace
is that as i say this government takes
the big decisions the tough decisions
that have been shirked for a generation
and never forget
the reason why we're in the position we
are is because it was a labor party in
1997 before their 13 years in power who
said there was no case no economic case
for more nuclear power with a
characteristic prescience
remind them of that every time they
complain about energy shortages energy
prices in our country my friends let us
get on with the job uniting and leveling
up across wells and across the whole
country with investment in roads and
rail across the north of wales
throughout the throughout the country
gigabit broadband i think i heard simon
mentioned that gigabit broadband which
is of such value to uh communities
particularly wrote a remote rural
communities
those infrastructure investments are
helping to drive jobs and growth across
the economy it is it is a massive and
exciting agenda for change
infrastructure skills
technology that is how we are going to
transform our country and make it fit
for the future can i just ask you do you
do you think at this juncture
when putin
is muttering recklessly
about
using his nuclear arsenal
do we really want our defense policy
handed over
to a bunch of
semi-repentant corbyn easter loons to
put it marvin
eight never forget eight of the shadow
front bench
including the shadow foreign secretary
voted to scrap this country's
independent nuclear deterrent is that
the right thing for our country now is
that the right thing for nato now is
that the right thing for the world for
ukraine absolutely not do we want labour
running the economy when there has never
when all they want all they ever want to
do
the prime minister speaking in wales
there will have more on that in just a
moment but first this is sky news coming
up today
should head roll now over partygate
prime minister
are you worried about the sugray report
prime minister
no apology for breaking lockdown rules
as the prime minister says he wants to
wait for the civil service's final
report
that would be entirely up to
sue gray and
we'll be i'll be
looking for very much to see what she
has to say
and
fingers crossed that will be that will
be pretty soon next week
cases of monkey pox more than double in
the uk as the global spread continues
ukrainian troops defending the steel
works in mariopol are ordered to stop as
more people are evacuated
[Music]
and football's pitch invasion problem
worsens with a manager now under
investigation